[Music]
it may be hard to tell but we're kind of
obsessed with a loud family in the loud
house like did you know there was
supposed to be 25 sisters instead of 10
keep watching to find out all the
interesting sisters that didn't make the
cut if you love the loud house be sure
to subscribe to the Thames now let's
meet ten deleted loud house characters
Brenda Brenda is a super grumpy rabbit
sister she wears a red shirt and skirt
to match her angry mood Brenda hates
everything including a girl she's never
met I hate her already she's kind of
like grouchy Smurf except she's a white
rabbit
she's always frowning and honestly we
can't really imagine placing her in the
Regular Show no one needs that much
negativity especially not a huge family
Tim Brenda would also be super mad about
the error that was made in animation
when she said her line she looked like
another rabbit sister family seriously
people they had one job Barbara Barbara
is the rabbit counterpart of Luna loud
she even dresses like Luna in a purple
dress although Brenda's dress is a lot
more freely than Lunas outfit she always
has a bit of music to play during action
scenes and she plays her guitar most of
the time her guitar is an acoustic
guitar while Luna typically plays an
electric guitar she's also not as rocker
chic as Luna just like Brenda Barbra had
an animation error too when she said
they needed chase music her purple dress
was suddenly pink
although we better character would be
totally chill about it Bailey Bailey is
the rabbit version of Lin loud she's
extremely athletic and she dresses like
she's ready to run
she wears a red baseball cap with a
yellow dot her Jersey is the opposite of
Lynn's Jersey instead of being white
with a red number one on it pers is red
with a white number one she wears red
workout shorts and always has a whistle
around her neck in the rabbit version
there's another athletic sister we bet
they got along great
Green loves seeing the look that
inspired Lin loud every family needs a
resident athlete Bella is totally emo
she's the bunny version of Lucy loud and
the only rabbit sister to not have white
fur instead she's great a match her
gloomy mood that kind of reminds us of a
certain gloomy gray donkey she's got
long bangs that cover her eyes and she
wears a black and white striped dress
she looks almost exactly like Lucy she's
edgy and depressed and just like Lucy
she is obsessed with poetry what's the
use life's just an endless stretch of
misery
occasionally brightened by despair we
think is hilarious to see such a goth
rabbit and we're glad she has a human
counterpart in the regular cast
Bernadette Bernadette is another bunny
sister that has a human loud counterpart
she's the counterpart of Lola loud she
was a pretty purple dress but although
she does not look as fancy as Lola she
does have the same bossy attitude
she is a total tattletale she threatens
to tattle to their mother on anyone who
doesn't do what she wants
she threatens Warren the rabbit version
of Lincoln just like she did in the very
first episode of the loud house we don't
know if Bernadette loves beauty pageants
like Lola but we think it's a safe
assumption
Beatrice fleece Aloud's bunny
counterpart is Beatrice Beatrice is
exactly like Lisa and behavior and she
is the smartest of the bunny sisters she
carries around a calculator and she even
has the same Lisp as Lisa even down to
the same thick glasses as her human
version her outfit is really the only
thing that's different she has a green
top like Lisa but the rest of her dress
is blue however Lisa's original concept
art had her in blue and green - Beatrice
is literally the original Lisa are you
loving these rabbit sisters keep
watching to find out one of the most
interesting deleted sisters Bethany
Bethany does not have a loud sister
version she's a totally new character
she wears a purple top with a blue skirt
and she keeps a pencil behind her ears
she's depicted as crazy organized she
keeps her really long to-do list and she
mostly does her own thing we assume
she's just trying to get that list
checked off Bethany got her name from
the creator Chris savino's wife we want
her if miss Savino is super organized
and we think Bethany would have made a
great addition to the loud family a
family with so much chaos could really
use some organizational skills Bernice
Bernice is one lucky rabbit she dresses
in Christmas colors but wears a
four-leaf clover on her head everything
is about luck - Bernice she even has a
lucky rabbit's foot which understandably
grosses out all of her siblings yeah we
get it although it's supposed to be
lucky it did belong to a rabbit and the
whole family consists of rabbits would
not be like a human carrying around a
human foot gross but Bernice is kind and
willing to share her luck she offers the
rabbit's foot to her brother Warren
she's definitely an interesting addition
to the family
Bertha much like Bayley Bertha is an
extremely athletic rabbit
she wears orange gym clothes and an
orange sweat band on her head Bertha is
dedicated to staying hydrated she always
has her orange water bottle with her we
imagine that she and Bailey kept the
whole bunny family in shape Bertha may
have been ditched from the show but her
name was used in another episode Big
Bertha is the toilet auger from the
episode sleuth and consequences Bertha
is pretty hilarious but we understand
why she was deleted from the show one
athlete out of 10 is plenty there aren't
enough interesting sisters without her
Bianca and finally we have the funny
sister Bianca don't confuse her with
Laurie and Carols rival we bet the
original rabbit is where that character
got her name Bianca is an artist she
wears a striped shirt blue skirt in a
purple beret which really cements her
artists vibe she paints in oils and has
a tendency to paint whatever is
happening she painted a picture that she
called portrait of a clueless boy being
saved by his sisters we love her sass
and we think she would have made a great
addition to the loud family which of
these rabbit sisters is your favorite
let us know in the comments section and
those are 10 deleted characters from
Nickelodeon the loud house be sure to
like this video and subscribe
[Music]